encore une fois j'ai d'abord
comprenez-moi bien moi je ne m'engage
pas un plan d'économies de l'assemblée
nationale je suis pas venu présenter ça
je vous dis je fais deux choses avec
florian bacheliers est l'organe a aussi
premièrement j'essaie de changer des
dépenses qui n'ont plus lieu d'être
pour les anciens présidents de
l'assemblée pour les anciens députés qui
continue à rouler entre un sac ou depuis
cent mille euros par an et de redéployer
les économies dans deux directions 1 une
diminution du budget de l'assemblée
pour participer à la division la dépense
publique 2 m'améliorer le statut du
parlementaire on a dans l'idée de faire
deux choses que je vous ai pas dit
encore on sait si vous voulez je vous le
dis là avec fleurs au match aller 1
d'augmenter le crédit collaborateur
clairement qu'il est barnes c'est à dire
en gros l'enveloppent qui permet de
salariés à des collaborateurs elle est
plutôt vraiment insuffisante en france
est la plus basse quasiment tous les
pays européens
ces économies elles ont vocation à
revaloriser l'enveloppent du crédit
collaborateur et deuxièmement
d'augmenter également la capacité
informatique numérique des
parlementaires parce que ça suffit pas
aujourd'hui on est au 21ème siècle et
les parlementaires ne se suffisent pas
de charge justement c'est franchement et
un mot sur l'autel de bras et si je peux
me permettre si vous aviez président
m'en parler l'assemblée nationale avait
prévu d'acheter la vache telle erreur à
l'état tout le pâté de maison à côté
pour s'agrandir
ça coûte 60 3 millions d'euros il ya
plus de 40 millions d'euros de travaux
prévus moi je veux bien qu'on parle
dit-il cuillère de l'appartement de
faïence bacheliers mais voyez 103
millions d'euros tout 100 millions
d'euros de dépenses au moment où le
parlement aurait passé de 577 à 400 moi
je ne serai pas celui qui ira expliquer
aux français que moment on enlève un
tiers des effectifs de cette maison on
va dépenser plus de 100 millions d'euros
pour s'agrandir